[Music]
we're able to sort of recreate kind of
everything as faithfully as it was on
the day building our movie around her
and so that involves steaming out the
station of the other characters as well
it's literally like a gift from her or
her forcing us to make her the star of
the movie but probably both this is the
first thing we're doing with layout and
of course you don't have the most
important person this I would say is you
know in most levels but that's the last
thing they've carried it stand for so
instead I would say let's have every
moment be one of celebration for a woman
we love the character we fill up
environment the reality of having to do
a scene with someone who isn't actually
there yes master was very difficult I
saw had to walk often had a moment being
back has been incredible painful surreal
[Music]
all of the adjectives that you can come
up with probably I felt
it was a hard day but it was it was a
good day
we've had tears and we've had you know
after memories man and the fact that
there were so many people around talking
so fondly of her and you know sharing
our memories of her you know and with
Billy to be able to listen to you know
how people think of them um you know
there's no one in the entire cast and
crew that was more supportive than Billy
and sort of know that we were doing this
with sort of her at our side that's
something I'll just always be grateful
to her for I'm so happy and she would be
happy that it's her boobie - it's
fascinating to watch an actress come
into a role like ray and to be 19 20
years old even the idea of getting
strong physically all of that was new
and now as she's emerging as a powerful
Jedi and you're watching her as Daisy
actually moved through that process
there's an interesting parallel I went
into it knowing that I wanted to be
healthy doing stuff that literally feels
good for your body so I was sort of
combining a number of things so I was
doing essentially body weight training
five days a week and then kickboxing
twice a week I took karate kendo and did
a little bit of weight training they
sort of want to mix that martial arts
flavor in with the traditional foil
fencing yeah we have to rest
I can't talk now I'm out of breath
becoming better than Errol Flynn what do
you mean by difficult this is unusual
you know I haven't seen this one before
then you pull the saber out here we go
this remote Troy it's molded from the
original world from a new hope the one
that he is then so that's exactly the
same as what he saw on the fountain on a
new house many possible that moment
where they all arrived Poe looks up and
he sees this immense fleet kind of
reminded me of that sort of Dunkirk idea
that everyone in the galaxy comes
together to try and take down the first
order and the set the blockade runner
will be there in x-wings but along with
that we've thrown in just about any ship
we could find we've got the Naboo
Starfighter from the Phantom Menace
we've got the ghost from rebels the Star
Tours ship medical frigate from Empire
Strikes Back Ewing from rogue one the
resistance bomber from last Jedi this
ship is a Mandalorian ship that goes all
the way back to the Clone Wars episodes
three of the aces from Star Wars
resistance you might notice a quad
jumper from force awakens very similar
to the approach that we took with the
x-wing where we looked at early
McQuarrie drawings we designed a newbie
wing it's kind of slicker a little
thinner lighter but taking inspiration
from Joe Johnston he designed a lot of
great early B wing designs that
eventually made it to what you see in
return the Jedi we've also upgraded the
Y wing the wing so initially we thought
our library was going to be big enough
to include all these ships that we were
going to need but we soon realized when
JJ said thousands of ships we needed to
go back to the drawing board and design
a lot of ships about 55 new ships that
we had never seen before
if I oppose this it's crazy
I'm got along to kind of sell it to the
audience and so little subtle clues in
costume the look of that and also the
set will allow us to do that very
quickly I guess we call him wicket son
you know I think in in realities my son
but also in within the tribe has indeed
produced an offspring he's older wiser
and he has a little scamp
to to handle now so you can imagine the
scale of immense the crowd of Harrison
and what he's achieved today if it's not
easy in this you know it's it's
difficult to move it's extremely hot you
can't see you can't breathe and he did
he did a sterling job
how was that I drew this myself while I
was waiting for you guys to people yeah
I always loved making discoveries
planning things as much as we can and of
course you storyboard and you shot lists
but the truth is that when you're on the
set you discover things that you know
you need that you never would have known
right he's right around here the thing
hits that's behind it if you're looking
back over your left shoulder
no I missed this game and then the whole
thing comes around like that
twice just as I still see the Sun is
normal so interestingly we need to turn
the whole speed around
[Music]
was really exhilarating for me it was
the most fun I've had but it's a bit
challenging because they'd have fans as
well and so you just have all this sand
getting into your eyes and I'd go home
after after some days and just like tons
of sand would be pouring out of my hair
[Music]
three two Eunice has a confidence that
is really exciting to work with she's
ferocious in a way that you want people
to be and when you have people like that
then you've trust their opinion and it
challenge you to make it better and more
specific there's no icebreaker without
them you just it's not simple I actually
love it I love it even in rehearsals
Adams in character
I'll go Adam you need to step out more
it's closing your strengths down he's
like no no don't need to step on more
kylo Ren wouldn't be like that he wants
it there he wants it there and not be
like yeah boy yeah boy I mean after this
this like argument I like it characters
were starting place it's never from
spectacle it's always from within he was
like so this is how it is Eunice I do
all my own stunts um like you here we go
I always had it I go out there's a level
you can do and there's a lovely cut no
no no no you know I'm I do it all the
physicality of Kyle oh I'm very
protective over so you kind of I wanted
to do all the love all of the things I
was like well okay if it looks good you
can do it if it doesn't look that good
I'll be putting a stunt guy in it has to
look good so what he did everything
oh we've done
all this time
I want you to know that you have been a
real friend of to my best one in fact
[Music]
before
for us together
[Music]
a real Ennis Whatley started
[Music]
about thousand generations live in you
now
this is your destiny
[Music]
be with you boys
[Music]